I'm not even really looking for I'm
sorry I'll take it I think there are a
lot of apologies owed but it's really
not what I want what I want is your rock
solid assurance that you understand what
happened and will never do it again
that's what I want I want safety going
forward for me my kids all of the people
who stood with us against this madness
those people deserve never to face that
again in their life and to the extent
that people I don't even think they
understand that they switch sides MH you
were told you were telling people get
your shot if not you're a bad person and
now you're not getting your
shot and you don't maybe you think
you're putting it off no you're afraid
you now realize how dangerous these
things are you're afraid to get it as
you should be but that fear we tried to
tell you back before you got any of them
and now is the time for you to say you
know what that didn't sound true to me
at the time I now know how confused I
can be I won't do that again no more
witch hunting I'm out I will not hunt
witches because witches don't exist
witches are the people trying to tell
you this is not good for you or your
children yeah I think that it's it's
hard
because you for people like us that have
been so deep down
this sort of you you know they you would
call it a rabbit hole right there's
people that are not even on the
circumference of it up top they are
100,000 miles that direction and you're
right you know they don't know they
don't know that they've switched sides
because they're just kind of following
the wave of things and it really
illustrates actually just how um you
know it illustrates that mass formation
right that that we've all sort of fallen
in line not all of us have fallen in
line with but so many have everything
has sort of become a football team so to
speak whereas what team are you on are
you on team mask or anti- science
altogether right there's these big
labels on the other side um and I think
that there's a huge swath of people that
know you know innately something's wrong
but they don't know how they don't have
the information they're just waiting to
see where it goes and and and and a lot
has happened because of people like us
breaking down that narrative piece by
piece and it's really good to see it but
yeah I think I like your way better you
know in the sense of just like the
assurance that look you know you don't
even have to say you're you're sorry
just don't do it again and promise me
that that's actually exactly right yeah
I mean seriously that that is the deal I
will explicitly make if you put if you
put it right so that we know where you
stand you're clear about it and you're
not going to do it again we're Square I
don't need your apology right I know
that you probably thought you were doing
the right thing at the time I get that
yeah but it needs to never happen again
because we're talking about like the
literal safety of
children it couldn't be more important
do you feel like that um outside of
music that there there's enough people
sort of waking
up well again I think the core issue is
this a huge number of people are some
what awake mhm and if they could be just
driven hey time to get up it's the rest
of the way you got to go right you you
saw something you know you don't want
that shot now let's work backwards and
figure out how it is that people got to
the point of mandating something upon
you that you now realize was never in
your interest what does that mean what
does that require of you I do think that
they could wake up but at the moment
they're too comfortable because it's
fine for them not to say not to tell you
that they've switched sides sides not to
even confess to themselves that they're
never going to get the shot right so so
I want I want the people who are who are
somewhat awake to go the rest of the way
then there's a tremendous amount of uh
of Hope there are a lot of people a huge
a huge majority are are now
[Music]
skeptical